yes
what's something that you learned
you had a great pandemic i had a great
pandemic in terms of just
where we were before we started to where
we are now what is uh something that you
took away from
you know the goofy era of our country
or the world rather the world yeah
content is king
guys like shoals watching how they
released
um content is also recession proof it's
pandemic proof for sure it's
in fact it's needed more in those
moments yeah people were running out of
[ __ ] to watch oh for sure i read through
a whole lot of netflix
oh yeah no i went back and re-watched
prison break i was just at the crib just
losing my [ __ ]
yeah i was [ __ ] awesome at first it
was like every other thing the first
season got weird yeah yeah they got a
weird season three they all do broke
right
they end up in jail again in colombia
yeah i'm like how many [ __ ] times can
you end up in [ __ ] jail yeah jesus
y'all milked the drunk utter dry son one
and two spitting does so good so good
they gotta quit [ __ ] legacies up
another show that was like that oh
dexter got weird after season four
the new dexter
was equal what'd you think about the new
dexterity was all right i appreciate i
liked it because i hated the way dexter
ended yeah it was so corny so i was kind
of glad that they kind of
brought it back full circle did you ever
see dynasty or whatever it's called um
that might have been what it was called
it was a show about a family who like
had a big dynasty and
it's like it was awesome i got to look
at it i mean my wife watched it it was
so good like season three it turned into
a [ __ ] musical
literally these [ __ ] turned this
[ __ ] show that was like savage
gangster cutthroat business [ __ ] and it
was [ __ ] musical and i was like y'all
[ __ ] blew it i think five is the
sweet spot
if you really gotta you gotta end it at
five for sure all the best shows the
wire was five seasons breaking bad was
five seasons ozark four but two parts
right
yeah because i think after you did how
many was sons of anarchy
too many was it like seven it was like
seven or eight yeah
but it was great
it still i loved it you know the way we
knew it would but i just
sons of anarchy when peg bunny stabs uh
dax's [ __ ] uh [ __ ] wife in the
head his baby mom oh my god yeah
she was a
you watch mayans
no i heard i got a couple of friends who
play on it that are awesome joseph and
them are really good
i heard it's really good too
yeah i'm [ __ ] with yellowstone
there's a new show with jeff bridges
called the old man that's crazy three
episodes in
is it already all out is it coming no
it's once a week [ __ ] call me when it's
finished the big lebowski's in i've been
[ __ ] myself getting into those things
and i'm on the road so i always miss
when it comes out dude the boys season
three starts with this [ __ ]
superhuman dude like there's like people
in the show with powers it's about
essentially it's like
uh
if superheroes were real right they'd be
like corrupt they'd have drug problems
they'd be [ __ ] [ __ ] they'd be like
taking advantage of people like so it's
like that angle the superhero thing
and like the captain america of the show
like the fa like the biggest superhero
in the country is like a [ __ ]
sociopath serial killer
[ __ ] rapist maniac
and everyone's scared of him because
he's got like what's this show yeah it's
called the boys it's on amazon prime
it's amazing but season three starts
there's this like dude who's kind of
like ant-man right yeah so he's [ __ ]
at some gay club
and he takes his dude into the room and
it looks like he's about to get [ __ ]
in the ass
and uh
the the dudes are descriptive so the
dude the dude bends over
and it's like jump in yeah so the
superhero guy
goes super tiny like ugh small enough
and he dives in the tip of this guy's
dick no [ __ ] way so he's inside of
the guy's dick yeah and he's like
tickling the sides and when he sneezes
he gets big again
so
he sneezes
inside the guy's dick and explodes the
dude all over the phone oh my god it's
crazy this is the [ __ ] you're sitting
and then you're watching mushrooms and
this is what you're doing with your life
kicks in the door right finds him the
guy he puts the little [ __ ]
[ __ ] into a bag of cocaine and
shakes it up he dies of an overdose
yeah besides dying of an overdose it's
kind of a dream scenario for me i wish i
could just go swim around the bag of
cocaine i might do that tonight to be
honest where's the bag
it might be the way i get over this
hangover from plane drinking this
morning